ça va tous mes petits poteaux c'est
parti pour votre rush d'adrénaline
matinale grâce à nous l'émission est
numéro
tu vois où je me connais je vois
tu as pourri gâté ses enfants excuse moi
de faire de mon mieux alors que je les
élève seule vous ne vous rendez pas
compte de la chance que vous avez ici
si j'étais le père noël survolerait
cette maison san marino peu trop tout
pour les leçons de morale nous vous
remercions de tout ce que vous avez fait
ici à wml eux mais nous avons décidé de
suivre une autre direction
alors comme ça tu nous fout dehors c'est
très dur pour tout le monde sauf pour
moi je gagne lourd mais genre vraiment
ce que je vais dire aux gamins bras noël
approche et je me fais dire et on a
traversé des épreuves fillon va
traverser celle là depuis la mort de
leur mère
je pensais je vous dis papa fort j'étais
persuadé de de les avoir mis à l'abri de
tout ça aurait dû montrer que tu es t
au-dessus de ça et si je te disais crhb
qu elle est à vendre
c'est dans cette radio a connu ses
premiers succès font de vrais l'acheter
avec quoi mon charme et dévastateur
je veux que vous essayez de voir les
choses en un peu plus grand c'est une
chance en or de nous en sortir alors
retourner dans notre ancienne mois oui
et nous on est certain que ça va faire
beaucoup trop de monde à elle est toute
petite
faut se rendre à l'évidence on est dans
la mouise toi t'es gentil tu finis ta
pizza
je suis viendrait toujours à vos besoins
c'est prêt pour le crunch sur wb cul ça
c'est mon rôle dans sa victoire
[Musique]
l'important c'est parce que tu vas tu
sais ce que tu as déjà autour de tout
et que tu fais tout pour y arriver mon
coeur va exposer tellement je t'aime
[Musique]
est ce que ton paternel et na waie et
ils vont être nombreux à grimper aux
rideaux